Transcriber: Çise Ak
Gözden geçirme: Ali Eren Kayhan
Ben bir ihtilal çocuğuyum.
1980 yılının Eylül ayı
benim için çok önemliydi.
Ortaokulu bitirdiğim ve liseye
hazırlandığım yıllar
13 yaşındayım.
Genç kızlığa aday olduğum günler.
İlk defa büyük bir doğum günü kutlamasını
heyecanla bekliyorum.
Akşamdan sünger bigudilerle de saçlarımı
sardığını hatırlıyorum.
Giyeceklerim de  yatağımın başucunda.
Annem iki katlı pastayı hazırlamış.
Arkadaşlarımızı da çağırmışız.
O hayallerle akşam uykuya daldım.
Saat 05 suları idi.
Evde bir telaş, bir hareket, bir sesler...
Tam anlamlandırmaya çalışıyorum,
ne olduğunu. Ve babamın anneme
seslenişini duydum.
“Gül, ihtilal olmuş!”
İhtilal ne demekti ki?
Tam anlam vermeye çalışırken
salona gittim.
Sokakta askerler var.
Serhat türküleri ve sokağa çıkma
yasağı ilan edilmiş.
O gün ihtilal benim için doğum günümün
elimden alınışıydı sadece.
tabii ki ihtilal kelimesine yüklediğim
anlam, 20′li yaşlarımda farklılaştı.
Otuzlu yaşlarımda 40′lı ve 50′li
yaşlarında farklılaştı. Böylece...
hayatıma ben bir ihtilal çocuğuyum
cümlesi de damgasını vurmuş oldu.
Liseye geçtiğimiz yıllarda ihtilalin
izlerini çok daha fazla yaşamaya başladık.
Ben kimim, ne olacağım, nereye gidiyorum?
Bütün bu soruları sorardık birbirimize.
Aslında birazcık galiba elimizden tutan
birilerine ihtiyacımız vardı,
dertleşeceğimiz.
Bir çaresi vardı.
İlerde bir şeyler olacak diyen ve
o konuda ben çok şanslıydım.
Benim bütün gücüm yanımdaydı, ilham
kaynaklarım, sevgili annem ve babam.
Babam bir asker evladı.
1933 doğumlu ve o bin dokuz yüz kırk
sekiz ekonomik kriz ne çok ciddi
yüzleriyle yaşamış biri.
Zannediyorum İkinci Dünya Savaşı sonrası
ve herhalde Cumhuriyet'in yükselişinde de
mühendis olma kararını ülkesine
hizmet etmek üzere aldı ve bir
makine mühendisi oldu.
Annem bir asker kızı.
1944 doğumlu.
1958 yılındaki ikinci ekonomik krizi.
O da en büyük izleriyle yaşamış
biri ve evimizin en yaratıcı,
en güleryüzlü ekonomisti.
Zannederim böyle farklı zamanlarda ama
aynı kaderi yaşamış iki insanın çocuğu
olmaktan sonra 12 Eylül tarihi benim
doğum günüm için bir tesadüf değildi.
Ondan hiçbir zaman dış şartla
bir suçlama arzlarda.
Evinizde her zaman ben ne yapabilirim
sorusunu söylerdik.
Kader diye bir şey var diye bir
şeyin üstünde durmaz tık bile.
Dolayısıyla kendi içimde beni bile
şaşırtacak güçlerin olduğuna
inanarak büyüdüm.
Önemli olan o güçleri keşfetmek, sonra
uyandırmak ve eyleme geçirmek olacaktı.
İşte o zaman ihtilal içimizde idi.
O yıllarda dışarıdaki sohbetlerde
“gençlerin hayalleri mi çalınıyor?”
kısmında hep bazı sohbetlere arkadaş-
larımızla birlikte kulak kabartır attık.
Çok fazla itibar etmezdim, üstünde durmaz.
Ama arkadaşlarımızla yaptığımız o dertli
sohbetlerin dibinde bunlar vardır ve
onların çok etkilendiğini de görürdüm.
Biraz o sohbetlerde suskun
olmayı yerlerdi.
Belki de geleceğimiz için bir şeyler
söyleyebilecek elimde materyal yoktu.
Onun için de susardım.
Ta ki aslında aktif bir dinleyici olma
becerisinin hayatımı hatta geleceğime yön
vereceğini keşfedene kadar. Geleceği
düşünürken o yıllarda istemekle başarmak
arasında aslında zayıf bir ilişkinin
olduğunu da tahmin ediyordum tabii ki.
Yani başarılı olmak için istemek şart.
Bu kesinlikle ama çok iyi bir
ses sanatçısı olamazdım.
Çünkü hançerem buna müsaade etmezdi.
O zaman hayatımıza baktığımız zaman
başarılı olabilmek için o içimizdeki
tutkuları, becerileri, ilgileri,
entellektüel kısmı, tutkuları ortaya
çıkarmak ve bütün enerjimizi oraya akıtmak
gerektiği noktasında çok büyük
bir içsel motivasyon taşıyordum.
İstediğiniz şeye ne kadar yatkın
olduğunuzu bilmek ve bu yatkınlığınızın
dış güçler tarafından aslında takdir
edilmesi, teşvik edilmesi ve bunu hayatım
boyunca olumlu etkileriyle hep yaşadım.
Belki bugün sizler “biz pandemi dönemi
gençliğiyiz” diyeceksiniz ve 2050′li
yıllarda bu dönemin ekonomik, sosyal,
duygusal tüm yönlerini öğrencilerinize,
evlatlarınıza, belki torunlarınıza
anlatıyor olacaksınız.
Ve en önemli şey aslında
yaşamda seçtiğimiz yol.
Yaşamda seçeceğiniz yol ya da yaşamda
şu gün yaşadığımızı nasıl anlam verdiğimiz
bize bir avantaj ya da
dezavantaj olabilir.
Seksenli yıllarda ben bunları düşünürken
2021′li yıllarda gençler
neler düşünüyor acaba diye
çok merak ettim.
Onun içinde gençlere sordum.
Gerçek hedeflerinizi ulaşabileceğiniz
düşünüyor musunuz?
1 ve 5 arasında ölçekler indirdik.
Sizde var olan becerilerinizi, ne
oduğuna, gelişmiş olan becerilerinizi ne
olduğuna inanıyorsunuz, ikinci soruydu ya
da geliştirilmesi açık becerilerinizi ne
olduğuna inanıyorsunuz?
Bu grubun iki yüz kişiye yakın belki
küçük bir grup ama anlamlı
veriler vardı içinde.
Çok değerli veriler vardı.
Yüzde doksan biri içindeki tutkuyu
yakalayıp ona sarılacam
cevabı verdi.
Ölçeklendirmede biri seçti.
Bravo size.
Sadece akademik beceriler, gelişmeye açık
becerilerin ve kendi ve güçlü hissettiği
beceriler kısmında biraz garip
karmaşıklık vardı.
Çünkü öğrenilmesi, getiriler ve
yöntemlerle beceriler arasında
kafalar karışık.
Ama şunu da söylemeliyim.
Evet, yüzde 80'ini fizikte, kimyada,
biyolojik çatışma yöntem ve tekniklerinde
gelişmeliyim derken ben iyi bir gözlemci-
yim ve detayları yakalayabiliyorum.
Sorumluluk bilincim yüksek, o kadar kolay
pes edebiliyorum ki, empati yeteneğim
güçlü insanlarla güzel ilişkiler kura-
biliyorum diyen tanımlamalarıda
müthiş buluyorum.
O zaman bu gençlik içinde hayalleri
ellerinden alınıyor sorusunun cevabını
onun arasında şu içi anketle
vermiş olsunlar.
Dış şartlar ne olursa olsun onlar
içlerindeki güçleri yakalayacak ve
sımsıkı tutunacaklar.
Ben de o yıllarda elimde olmayan
sebeplerden dolayı sürekli sızlanabilir.
Ya da hayatında çok ciddi olarak olumsuz
bir anlam yükleyebilirdim.
Ama ben de belli ki bugünün gençleri
gibi içimdeki güçleri
sömürmeye kadar vermiştim.
Baksanıza geçmişlerdi,
hatta o dinleyici olma becerinin bile
benim önümü açabileceğini düşünmem mi?
Evet, kesinlikle.
Psikoloji ve pedagoji bilimlerine duyduğum
ilginin bu beceri ile yakından
ilgisi olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Yine o yıllarda değiştiremeyeceğini,
şeylere takılma, değiştirebileceklerini,
aklın, tutku gibi zekanın
zorla mottom olmuştu.
Hiçbir zaman dış şartları suçlamadım.
Hatta içinden geçmiş olduğum dönem
benim en büyük kamçım olmuştu.
Ben bir ihtilal dönemi genç kızı olarak
ülkeme ve benden sonra gelecek olanlara
görevliydim aslında.
Tıpkı annem ve babam gibi.
O zaman önümüzde iki yol var ya;
hayatımızda gerçekten sürekli dış
şartları, etmenleri, koşulları,
seçemediklerimizi suçlayacağız ya da kendi
içimizdeki gücü, becerileri, ilgileri,
tutkuları o entellektüel ruhu tutacağız.
Yakalayacağız ve onun yolundan gideceğiz.
Şu anda hayatınızda yolunda gitmeyen
bir şeyler olabilir.
Hayatınızda yolunda gitmeyen bir
şeyler için de, dış şartları
suçluyor olabilirsiniz.
Bu konuda haklı da olabilirsiniz
ama başarılı olamazsınız.
Peki mutlu olabilir misiniz?
Sizin neyi sizin harekete geçirdiğini
keşfetmeniz çok kıymetli olacak.
Geleceğe ve dünyaya açılırken o içinizdeki
keşfi yapmanızı dilerim.
Bunun çok kolay bir şey olmadığını
biliyorum ama mümkün bir
şey olduğunu da biliyorum.
Özgüven zor bir şeyi yapabildikten
ve başarı geldikten sonra gelir.
Bu arzunuzun sıçrayışı elinizde.
Bunu sakın unutmayın.
Olur mu?
Teşekkür ediyorum
bildirgeleriniz için.